>> MY FELLOW HERENT, TONIGHT, I
AM SPEAKING TO YOU, BECAUSE
THERE IS A GROWING HUMANITARIAN
AND SECURITY CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
EVERY DAY, CUSTOMS  AND BORDER
PATROL AGENTS ENCOUNTER
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
TRYING TO ENTER OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE OUT OF SPACE TO HOLD THEM
AND WE HAVE NO WAY TO PROMPTLY
RETURN THEM BACK HOME TO THEIR
COUNTRY.
AMERICA PROUDLY WELCOMES
MILLIONS OF LAWFUL IMMIGRANTS
WHO ENRICH OUR SOCIETY AND
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR NATION.
BUT ALL-AMERICANS ARE HURT BY
UNCONTROLLED ILLEGAL MIGRATION.
>> THAT WAS THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT IN HIS ADDRESS, ON OUR
CRISIS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
JOINING US NOW IS HOMELAND
SECURITY, SECRETARY, KEY STEIN
NEILSON.
MADAME SECRETARY, GOOD TO SEE
YOU, YOU WERE IN THE SITUATION
ROOM TODAY, NOT A VERY LONG
MEETING.
NOT A PRODUCTIVE MEETING.
GIVE US YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> AS I SAID, I JUST AM SOLELY
DISAPPOINTED THIS A SEVERE
HUMANITARIAN AND SECURITY
CRISIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS TAKE
LEADERSHIP.
HE IS TAKE DECISIVE ACTION AND
CONGRESS IS REFUSING TO ACT.
THEY HAVE NO ALTERNATIVE.
THEY REFUSE TO ENGAGE AND IT'S
VERY, VERY DISAPPOINTING,
DISAPPOINTING ON BEHALF OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN, AND DISAPPOINTING
AS AN AMERICAN.
>> THEY'RE SAYING, THEIR PARTY
LINE THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
BUT WE DO KNOW THIS.
WE DO KNOW, 90% OF OUR HEROIN
COME THERE IS THE SOUTHERN
BOARDER AND WE HAVE 300 DEATHS
PER WEEK.
WE KNOW IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS.
WE LOST POLICE OFFICER SINGH,
AND HE HAS A 5-MONTH-OLD LITTLE
BOY.
HE WILL NEVER KNOW HIS FATHER.
WE KNOW PIERCE COCHRAN, HIS
PARENTS WERE ON THE SHOW EARLY
NETTER WEEK.
BEE DO KNOW THEIR 22-YEAR-OLD
SON, KILLED BY AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
DRUG TRAFFICKING, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE HAVE DRUG DEATHS, VIOLENCE,
CARTELS, GANGS.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE WHEN THEY
SAY IT'S MANUFACTURED WHEN THESE
ARE REAL PEOPLE, REAL LIVES,
LIFE AND DEATH AND THEY HAVE
JUST IGNORE IT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S OFFENSIVE.
IT'S DISRESPECTFUL.
I CAN'T IMAGINE BEING ONE OF
THESE VICTIM'S FAMILIES AND
LISTENING  TO AN ELECTED MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, CLAIM THEIR PAIN
AND SUFFER SUGGEST MANUFACTURED,
IT'S OFFENSIVE IS WHAT IT IS.
WE DO KNOW AMERICANS DIE.
I'D ARGUE PROBABLY 98% OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO COME HERE, WANT
HOPE, OPPORTUNITY, LIBERTY,
FREEDOM AND ALL THE THINGS WE
MAY TAKE FOR GRANTED OURSELVES.
BUT IT'S THE 2% I WORRY ABOUT,
THAT ARE PART OF THE GANGS, THE
DRUG CARTELS, THE 2% MAYBE YOU
HAVE TALKED B BUT YOU CAN'T GIVE
NUMBERS.
THERE ARE INSTANCES THAT YOU CAN
CONFIRM, THAT YOU KNOW OF
TERRORIST THAT IS HAVE TRIED
CROSS OUR SOUTHERN BOARDER AND
YOU'VE APPREHENDED THEM.
>> Y JOHN AND WE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE THOUSANDS, THE
THOUSANDS OF TERROR WATCH LIST
INDIVIDUALS THAT TRAVEL THROUGH
OUR HEME SPHERE LAST YEAR.
TO PRETEND THERE'S NOT A DANGER
ON AN YOU KNOW SECURED, OPEN
BORDER IS RIDICULOUS.
IT'S NOT JUST A SECURITY CRISIS
THAT THE PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO DRAW THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC'S ATTENTION TOM
IT'S A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
WE HAVE DOCTORS WITHOUT BORDERS
SAYING ONE IN THREE WOMEN ON
THIS JOURNEY ARE RAPED.
SEVEN OUT OF 10 OF THESE
MIGRANTS ARE VICTIMS OF
VIOLENCE.
THIS IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
THAT IS CAUSE BY THE THE HOLE OF
THE LOOPHOLES IN OUR LAW, BY OUR
LACK OF RESOURCES AND BY THE
REFUSAL DEMOCRATS  TO ACT.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE AND HOW DO
YOU EXPLAIN THAT CHUCK SCHUMER,
NANCY PELOSI, JOE BIDEN, BARACK
OBAMA, HILARY CLINTON, JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO, 2013 M THEY WERE
WILLING TO ALLOCATE $48 MILLION
FOR SECURITY AND THEY MAKE IT A
POINT ANOTHER NOT NEEDED ANYMORE
OR IT'S MANUFACTURED, BUT YET F
LOOK AT THE ONE SECTOR IN
ARIZONA, YUMA BORDER SECTOR, IT
WAS ONE OF THE WORST IN THE C
THEY WENT FROM FIVE MILES OF
BORDER FENCING  TO 63-MILES  AND
THEY SAW A REDUCTION OF 95% IN
APPREHENSIONS, AND PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO CROSS INTO THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
DOESN'T THAT PROVE THE POINT IN
THAT ONE COUNTY THAT IT WORKS?
WALLS WORK?
BARRIERS WORK.
>> WALLS WORK.
WE CAN'T SAY IT ENOUGH.
THE FACTS ARE INTROVERTABLE.
THOSE ARE THE FACTS.
THEY'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER
THEMSELVES, THEY CLAIM THAT THEY
HAVE TALKED TO OR BORDER PATROL
AGENCY, THEY CLAIM THEY FAVOR
BORDER SECURITY, BUT PRESIDENT
TONS MAKE CLEAR THIS IS NOT AN
EITHER, THIS IS NOT AN OR
SITUATION.
THIS IS AN AND.
WE NEED SECURITY AT OUR PORTS OF
ENTRY AND WE NEED SECURITY
BETWEEN OUR PORTS OF ENTRY.
>> THERE IS POLITICS BEING
PLAYED HERE, THOUGH, MADAME
SECRETARY.
IT WAS A CRISIS WHEN THEY COULD
BLUDGEON THE PRESIDENT
POLITICALLY AND SAY, THAT KIDS
WERE BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS, WHICH SHOULD HAPPEN IN
THE TWO PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS, AND THIS
PRESIDENT FIXED IT OR REQUEST
THEY CAN SAY, OUR BORDER AGENCY
WERE BEING PELTED  WITH ROCKS
AND BOTTLES, THEY CAN SAY, OR,
BORDER PATROL AND I.C.E. WERE
TEAR GASSING CHILDREN, SO IT
SEEMED TO BE A CRISIS WHEN THEY
COULD POLITICIZE TODAY.
BUT AMERICANS ARE DIEING IN BIG
NUMBERS BECAUSE OF THAT SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF THE CRIMINAL
ELEMENT.
DRUGS ARE COMING IN EVERY DAY.
AND WHAT DO YOU SAY WHEN PEOPLE,
WHEN LIVES ARE AT STAKE AND
PEOPLE ARE PLAYING POLITICS  IN
IT'S CLEAR, IT'S POLITICS.
>> I HATE THEY AGREE WITH YOU ON
THIS POINT, SEAN, BUT IT IS
POLITICS.
WHAT I THINK I WOULD SAY IN
RESPONSE IS THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT CONTINUE TO TAKE
LEADERSHIP.
THEY CONTINUE TO TRY TO SOLVE
THIS CRISIS.
THEY CONTINUE TO DESCRIBE IT FOR
WHAT IT IS.
THEY'RE DOING IT WITH
COMPASSION.
I THINK YOU SAW A PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT THAT WAS VERY SERIOUS THAT
WAS TAKING A LEADERSHIP ROLE.
HE WAS SHOWING COMPASSION AND
VERY IMPORTANTLY, MAKING IT
CLEAR THAT HE CONTINUES  TO
LISTEN TO THE MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE FRONT LINE AND PROTECT THIS
COUNTRY EVERY DAY, OFTEN AT A
DANGER TO THEIR OWN LIVES.
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
IS DOING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE DOING.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE OFFERS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EXPLAIND  TO
THEM WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THEY HAVE COME UP WITH NO
SOLUTIONS  ON THEIR OWN, BUT
THEY CONTINUE TO CLAIM AS YOU
SAID, THIS IS A MANUFACTURED
CRISIS.
NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER FROM